les libertés individuelles sont elles
menacées par le cos vie de 19 depuis le
début de l'épidémie chaque pays touchés
adopte sa propre stratégie numérique
pour faire respecter le confinement et
ralentir la diffusion du virus
traçage reconnaissance faciale
transmission de données tous les moyens
semblent bons pour lutter contre
l'épidémie
en israël une application de
surveillance a par exemple vu le jour
du nom de hama guen comprenez bouclier
en français et cette appli analyse les
données de géolocalisation de
l'utilisateur et le prévient s'il a
croisé des personnes infectées par le
virus
l'appli compare votre géolocalisation à
celle des patients infectés
lorsqu il y à un match entre les deux
vous recevez un lien du ministère de la
santé vous indiquant la marche à suivre
même dispositif en chine mais utilisé de
façon plus stricte
plus de 200 villes ont rendu obligatoire
le téléchargement d'un qr code sur le
téléphone portable de leurs habitants si
le code et vert alors tout va bien si
les oranges ou rouges l'utilisateur
devra rester en quarantaine durant 7 au
14 jours pour prendre l'avion le bus ou
entrer dans certains magasins il faudra
montrer patte blanche et présenter un
code vert mais pékin va encore plus loin
dans la surveillance de masse et grâce à
des caméras de reconnaissance faciale
les malades confinés chez eux sont
surveillés et repéré en cas de
non-respect de la quarantaine d'ici à
2022 l' empire du milieu vise un parc
total de 600 millions de caméras de
surveillance dans ces espaces publics
soit une pour deux personnes j'ai passé
du temps en chine et j'ai visité
certains centres de données ils ont
réellement mis en place une surveillance
de masse grâce aux informations
collectées
ils peuvent faire des profils savoir
quand une personne est allé chez le
médecin par exemple
maintenant ils surveillent la maladie
des gens de la même manière qu'ils
peuvent surveiller les criminels
autre outil de lutte contre le coc vide
19 le drone en australie au royaume uni
ou en espagne des drones ont été
utilisés pour diffuser des messages
invitant les populations à respecter le
confinement et ce n'est pas tout le port
du bracelet électronique se généralise
au delà de sa fonction initiale pour les
aménagements des peines de prison
l'italie envisage de rendre le
dispositif obligatoire pour les
personnes âgées afin d'optimiser
l'efficacité de son application de
traçage des personnes infectées à hong
kong des bracelets électroniques sont
distribués aux voyageurs en provenance
de l'étranger pour faire respecter les
mesures de quarantaine
en cas de non respect les contrevenants
s'exposent à une peine de prison de six
mois dans de nombreux pays le nombre de
cas confirmés peut être considérée comme
explosif si nous n'adoptons pas de
mesures strictes je crains que tous les
efforts de précaution déployer ces deux
derniers mois soit 20 pour contrer le
coville 19 certains pays déploie un
arsenal de technologies innovantes
certes mais particulièrement intrusive
qu'en est il en france faut-il
s'attendre à des mesures similaires une
expérimentation de vidéo surveillance
automatique a été déployé dans la
station de métro de châtier les halles à
paris
objectif vérifier que les clients
portent bien le masque désormais
obligatoire dans les transports en
commun la ratp assure qu'il n'ya aucune
finalité de verbalisation et qu'il
s'agit seulement d'une prise de données
pour des campagnes de sensibilisation
pourtant les défenseurs des libertés
monte au créneau
la démultiplication des solutions
technologiques à des fins de
surveillance et dangereuse on ne gagne
jamais en sécurité quand on perd en
liberté de son côté le gouvernement
compte sur l'application stop covin avec
un lancement prévu le 2 juin
cette application doit permettre de
tracer les malades et avertir ceux qui
les ont croisés vivement contesté cette
méthode de traçage numérique jeu
est contraire au respect de la liberté
et de la vie privée
le pays des droits de l'homme comme les
autres utilisent tous les moyens pour
contrarier la montée du coronavirus au
risque d'égratigner le premier principe
de sa célèbre devise liberté égalité
fraternité